it's a problem not many encounter a
recent customer just came to us and said
look my interior of my Aston Martin is
so beautiful but I want to have it in my
Ferrari how you do that this is what
ares offers taking high-end cars and
giving them a bespoke makeover so you've
changed that and you take if you
redesign everything new and you try to
fit it into the Ferrari and to try to
make the systems work again that's a
huge task a huge and expensive task
averaging six hundred thousand euros
this luxury modding service can rework a
supercar from head to toe interesting
companies like Ares is high the Asian
market in particular is investing more
and more into customization in China
alone it's estimated the customization
industry could be worth 17 billion euros
by next year back in 2009 who is worth
just four billion and big money means
big competition Lamborghini and Ferrari
already offer customization options with
half of Lamborghini customers paying on
average an extra fifteen percent on top
of the original cost to customize a
Ferrari it generally cost between twenty
and thirty percent but when it comes to
a complete overhaul sometimes you need a
third-party solution and you would like
to offer all of them the same
opportunity say I have a McLaren
it is too boring I would like to have my
own design I would like to change the
front I would like to change the
interior I would like to change the rear
and this is the main differentiator from
any other customization company you find
there so for the most cash ready
Motorhead's even a supercar the
supermodel